did you also hear the news just
yesterday
yeah i know you're going to see what of
sora getting uh confirmed for smash bros
oh yeah i guess the internet just
breaking i've never seen the internet
break yeah i mean that's hard i'm happy
for those fans who like sora i was
rooting for massachusetts literally
broke down crying as if like she lost a
family member does he play smash
she does oh okay but i didn't know
she played because she never played with
me yeah right but apparently she's
played like the 3ds variant and stuff
like like the old experiences yeah but
now there's i know there's going to be
just like a whole like
new smash players
yeah i mean i i you know i don't it's
one of those things where i'm happy for
those fans who got it but i don't really
care i yeah
i mean i i never played kingdom hearts
or me neither yeah
[Laughter]
i liked it i liked
were you hyped i i mean i was hyped just
purely on the base of like
just thinking to myself how the [ __ ]
like they must have thought for tooth
and nail with disney to get that maybe i
think i think i think maybe smash is big
enough where they would have been like
oh yeah i'm sure like sakura has done
enough now where he's just like
do you know who i am i mean i mean
uh probably
the releasing
which is probably one of the biggest
reasons why yeah i mean like i was more
surprised about minecraft steve yeah
yeah there is yeah i mean that did break
twitter yeah yeah that broke twitter as
well yeah because because like sora i
was just as as someone who's not that
invested in smash or kingdom hearts i
was like i see it was like because it
wasn't that big of a surprise for me
where i was just like what the [ __ ]
where did this come from it was just
like yeah i mean they had a cloud on
there they had uh
see this is why i wanted master chief
man it would have been so out of left
field yeah master chief would have been
imagine it right the the [ __ ]
announcement comes you hit the [ __ ]
halo music bro that would have been
like this is full for memes this is i do
not actually want i do not care if he is
in it or not but i just want the meme
potential that's what people were saying
about sands until they added yeah yeah
yeah yeah i just want i just want
masturbation i added a doom guy though
as a skin no yeah
one one of those skins is dude
though come on man could have been it
yeah no doom guy could have been it's
the final it
as well yeah the final after so there's
no more characters the next smash and
future whenever that happens we better
get the master chief well i mean you
know nickelodeon did a fighting game so
who knows like no no i know what i want
what is this nickelodeon fight against
[ __ ] it's basically nickelode they're
talking about all the nickelodeon
characters and turn into a special it's
like actually like like a well-designed
game yeah i've heard okay i don't know i
don't really care i saw a video of some
guy just saying how broken spongebob was
and
uh and i never thought i'd see the word
spongebob needs to get nerfed
written in text but like i saw and i was
like wow what a time to be alive
oh man
i want to go damn i don't know like like
i'm super happy like i personally have
never really like sat down playing the
kingdom hearts game like i only know so
much about it because i live with a
kingdom hearts fan like i'm i'm happy
for the kingdom hearts fans i just know
that every time you talk to a kingdom
hearts fan they try to explain the story
i'm just glad i don't know yeah i mean
it's like the you know it's it's it's
like as a fake fan it's just like i i
understand how it feels getting they
just love it
they [ __ ] love it it's whatever they
they can i'm glad they have something i
i wish i i wish i had something that i
got then i probably know more about the
kingdom hearts law
just purely because of arki yeah because
i had to sit down and watch her play all
of kingdom master iii and every turning
point i was like uh may i ask a question
several questions yeah i love the memes
of like mickey mouse wearing like a
black hood i don't understand yeah i
don't understand the context
that's king mickey but like yeah but
like mickey mouse is wearing a black
hood and i'm like all right
i should just like and he gets into the
darkness and he fights enemies i don't
know this is totally unrelated but it's
just reminding me of this the prep of
the rapper memes with the
daffy duck have you seen that one i
think so yeah yes i slammed my penis in
the car door memes have you seen
something i've seen that one
it's really weird when you just say that
all right
i spoke to emily and didis and we were
all like do you have you guys seen the
the daffy duck uh yeah daffy duck where
he slams his penis in the car door with
crap of the rapper
and we were like yes we love that meme
now it's like yes
it's such a dumb meme i'll show you it
later all right
it's very weird when you just say that
when i hear that out of context
it's one of those memes that passed very
fast but i found it so funny and i i i
realized i'm such a child that's sad
it's so funny
you're like crying
there's something in my eye yeah it's
just so funny
just the memory of this meme it's just
breaking this matter
i just had to talk about i don't know it
reminded me of the i don't know
yeah i just love though like
like again like
i'm not too invested in smash anymore
but every time they announce a new
character i'm like okay i always like
try and keep up to date with what the
community says
how it feels to like like the nba and
like have the draft yeah yeah it's like
just like all of the all of the
predictions i see from smash fans it's
just [ __ ] hilarious because with this
lost you could drop you can bet on the
characters with this last drop yeah like
some of the like there was three main uh
like you know predictions it was like
sora obviously yeah master chief
obviously third one was [ __ ] goku
oh and crash bandicoot it's not like
sure as well yeah crash bandicoot but
like go there was like an alarming
amount of people who were like
goku no
i'd be hyped for goku
and i'm like i'd be hype but
i just can't imagine a game where goku
beats up mario
and sonic and sonic it just sounds
kidding me weird that sounds amazing it
sounds amazing what's that i don't get
hype over there what's that game where
you bet on uh characters that fight um
it's like salty bets is that what it is
that's it that literally just turns into
salty it just turns out yeah yeah yeah
it just it just turns his face was just
like decades ahead of his time
fighting alucard yeah
sure
and then like how miku comes back from
one hp and destroys alexander you're
like that checks out that sounds good
oh my lord yeah